by Steven stone he's chief executive of
the property company crest Nicholson
Steven good to see you good evening
so the Chancellor wants to look into the
gap between planning permissions and and
housing starts he clearly thinks you're
all hoarding her hoarding London well I
think the secret is in the name crest
Nicholson house builder that is we buy
land and we build and sell houses that's
our job that's what keeps our share I
was happy and that's what pays the
salaries of our staff that's not to say
that there may be some around
speculators but I think as far as house
button is concerned all with a house
build as soon as we get a planning
consent we crack on build houses so you
don't think there is much evidence
Oliver let wind is going to find a house
builders hoarding land all over the last
what 15 years there's been three other
inquiries and all of them have found
that house builders get on and build
houses he's pretty he's threatening you
with some pretty severe um compulsory
purchase orders potentially isn't he
well I think as far as I'm concerned we
welcome this this review because I think
it'll show that house builders we do get
on build housing and what I hope it will
do is is come over the myth that there's
a difference between a consented site
with an outline planning consent and
then one enables us to start building
and what's often misunderstood is it can
take a year to get move that process on
and if we look at productivity in house
building it takes about six months to
build a house and eighteen months to get
a planning is then if we can shorten
that better productivity all around one
of the things that Chancellor mentioned
was he wants infrastructure to encourage
higher density house building is that
what people really want well it's a mix
there's now I think in urban situations
you need to build higher Hart more
density but out in rural areas you have
to you know create a housing density
that suits the local towns villages so
it's a mix of both in a word Steven he's
targeting three hundred thousand times a
year by the mid twenties is he going to
get there wait it's a tough tough call
and I have to say he wants to do it he's
got to start working on this today you
know he can't can't wait for another
year all right Steven sofa crest
Nicholson appreciate you joining me
thank you